this video is sponsored by zen market
what is good everybody it's been a hot
second since i covered naruto after i
took a break to cover spider-man and
well
yeah let's just say that i had a bad
month but i'm interested in moving
forward and finally getting back to this
naruto review with one of the most
feverishly awaited arcs i've yet covered
i didn't realize that when i took a
break from naruto it was right before
one of the most pivotal and beloved
parts of the series okay well i had some
idea but certainly not to this extent
today i will be reviewing breaking down
and sharing my appreciation for three
sections of this tale i will be tackling
each one individually starting with the
itachi pursuit mission moving on to the
tale of jedi the gallant and culminating
with the faded battle between brothers
buckle in because this is gonna be a fun
one
[Music]
before i dive into the attachy pursuit
mission i want to announce something fun
i've just finished up my reviews for
every live-action spider-man film where
i dedicated each video to one of the
three main actors who'd don the mask
over the last 20 years toby andrew and
tom respectively and i had so much fun i
wanted to see if i could do something
similar to that again but with a little
twist the new batman movie entitled the
batman starring robert pattinson is
slated for release in the first week of
march 2022 and fun fact outside of the
dark knight movie batman vs superman
sort of and i guess joker i'm not
familiar with the character at all so i
was thinking what if i reviewed every
live-action batman movie from the 1966
adam west incarnation of the character
all the way to the modern great batflick
of the justice league which i also
haven't seen i will begin this two-part
semi-blind review series on february 19
2022 and in preparation for this i'll be
reading up on the original comics as
well as reading some of the very best
stories before i jump into this mostly
blind review of the batman films in an
effort to figure out who was the best
batman ever and what was the best batman
movie in my opinion this should be fun
and i hope to see you there
the itachi pursuit mission
[Music]
that was the first sentence of this arc
and with it commences a brilliantly
twisting and turning set of stories
filled with incredible battles
definitely the best in the series i
think all centered around two characters
and their fated conflicts sasuke's
pursuit of his brother itachi there's a
lot to cover in this video i haven't
covered naruto since before the holidays
and i think this was my most enjoyable
experience when reading the material so
far whether that has more to do with my
heart growing fonder from absence or
whether it's the contents of these three
incredible arcs telling of the story
i'll leave it up to you to judge in an
effort however to make sure this video
doesn't last a million years i'll be
dividing this video into three natural
sections the first the itachi pursuit
mission the second tale of jiraiya the
gallant and of course finishing with the
fated battle between brothers each of
these will have their own metaphorical
and thematic strings i hope i pick up
and each has their battles holy hell do
they have their battles but one thing i
hope won't be lost here is that while i
am dividing this video into three
sections i want to communicate that this
story does a seamless job of perfectly
and naturally connecting each and every
arc together implementing the words and
teachings of previous arcs to bolster
and in many cases greatly enhance the
power of certain key moments and the
first sentence of this arc is no
different so long as you have mercy you
can't best itachi this is a poisonous
mentality that clearly speaks to the
corruption that dwells deep within
sasuke's would-be kidnapper orochimaru
however this arc takes a twist very
early on that i did not see coming
now this is an interesting fight to kick
things off with and honestly it's not
because it's competitive in fact it's
not competitive at all but what it does
show us is that there's an air of i
don't know narcissism or perhaps ego
attached to sasuke now sasuke has
nothing left to gain from rochimaru and
so he absorbs him which is i guess fair
and still self-preservation outwardly
however sasuke in this carries with him
a quiet confidence with everyone around
and you can hear this in how he speaks
to orochimaru and the people he recruits
afterwards into his four-man cell group
but one thing that led me to suspect
that there was still so much more to
sasuke than he was letting on was his
dedication too at numerous points in
this story to spare various individuals
lives if he could help it which again
flies in the face of what orochimaru
told him in this arc's opening line
citing that he needs to strip himself of
mercy but anyway a large portion of this
first section is dedicated to setting up
these chess pieces in this metaphorical
chess game would that be taken from a
combat strategy sense with sasuke
recruiting the likes of sugetsu karen
and jugo karen introducing her first
seems to be the least complicated right
off the bat she offers a useful set of
senses and skills for sasuke's team but
for the most part her contributions
serve support and comedic purposes
mostly with her admiration of sasuke and
his sweaty grubby clothes making for a
character that teeters the line between
gross and funny jugo on the other hand
is sort of the hulk to sasuke's black
widow he's got this intense desire to
kill that he's overcome by from time to
time however sasuke seems to be able to
grant this man the freedom from his mind
that he's yearned for for what seems
like a long long time and if
introductions were anything to go by i'd
say that he's even more simple than
current which brings us to my favorite
of the members recruited sugetsu outside
of me really enjoying his design there's
such a weird confident and almost
chaotic nature to how this person
conducts himself around both sasuke and
others furthermore on this chessboard
naruto and the rest of the protag
shinobi ready themselves for this
pursuit they recognize that sasuke is
after hitachi and so they pursue hitachi
also in the hopes of finding sasuke
first oh and in classics shown in
fashion the hero is told that their most
powerful technique is too risky to use
which means he will definitely use this
move and it is going to be awesome when
he eventually uses it and so now with
sasuke and naruto's team formed and
their target set it's time to start this
chase and what better way than with one
of the most surprisingly brilliant
fights i've enjoyed in this series cat
daedara vs sasuke this fight totally
took me by surprise
grab my attention and never let go to
tell you the truth i enjoyed daedara as
a character in the past but i never
really connected to them until this
fight where the full scope of sasuke's
power can be observed and where the
unbridled creativity of daedara can
change the tide of a given conflict at a
moment's notice and this is a quick
aside this fight is split between two
volumes and the only reason i mentioned
this is because volume 40 has the best
cover art i've seen from kishimoto to
date hands down no contest there's such
a wonderful sense of kinetic energy to
its line art which is fitting because
this fight is the exact same though when
reading the manga variation of this
fight what i appreciated the most was
the borderline absurd level of
near-misses fake-outs and swerves with
more twists and turns than a curly fry
as often is the case with these
substantial fights we received the
backstory and some new information
concerning deidara we learn a little bit
more about his motivations and oddly
enough it turns out that this fight has
a bit more weight to it now with these
two combatants yearning to surpass the
same person itachi furthermore and i
feel this is worth saying at this time
when i sit down to digest these volumes
of manga i do so while taking notes from
my script notes where i expand upon an
impression i'm getting or perhaps jot
down a few useful talking points or
ideas for the video i try to be as
eloquent as i can in order to
effectively convey the emotion or
technique at play in the story for
myself later but when daedara used his
best move on sasuke this is what my
notes were daytora's [ __ ]
disintegrated sasuke
no seriously my script actually says ah
and also this sentence explaining but
back to the fight it appears that in
order to survive that attack sasuke used
the sharingan to see the attack coming
and dodge he blindsides daedara but wait
daedara is playing 40 chess and boom
literally sasuke does reverse the
situation again for the second time but
they change this one up and tied it back
to the beginning of the fight while also
adding the types chart into the mix
which was explored and introduced in the
previous section of the story his
chidori was favorable against daedara's
style of jutsu and he knew it from the
start but daedara still had one last
trick up his sleeve
this fight was honestly full of ups and
downs twists and turns interesting
reveals and callbacks to previously
established techniques that made perfect
sense for the time
and the way this fight ends creates the
best outcome for both daedara and sasuke
daedara puts some respect on his name in
the eyes of everyone including us the
audience not just by how creative he was
in his application of this incredible
power but also because of what sasuke
did in response to this attack to
protect himself summoning orochimaru's
giant snake to sacrifice and ultimately
protect himself against the oncoming
nuke in other words sasuke appeared
level-headed and incredibly resourceful
all the while daedara despite losing
unleashed one of if not the most
powerful attack we've yet seen in this
series i adored this fight it's next
level great
uh holy [ __ ] okay uh so cards at the
table i knew about this character before
i started reading or really i should say
i knew what he looked like but
apparently i knew less than i
anticipated because i honestly thought
that this was just some weird power up
for naruto similar to sasuke's one but
apparently he's just some new character
called pain i feel incredibly dumb right
now
there's a wonderfully heartfelt parting
conversation between jiraiya and tsunade
right here and while he never explicitly
says anything to tsunade about him going
on a mission with a low success rate he
knows that this is an important thing
for him to do not just as a high-ranking
and skilled shinobi but also as a mentor
to the next generation upon finishing
this arc this was the scene that stood
out to me as particularly attention
grabbing he wanted a chance to have a
drink with her and told her how he
respected her there was a specific focus
on his most wonderful qualities with a
sense of i don't know melancholy hanging
in the air despite tsunade saying that
he is to return regardless once i reach
the end of this act with sasuke standing
face to face with hitachi i felt a very
uneasy feeling for the future of jiraiya
as he arrived at the location of pain
before we continue i want to introduce
you guys to something really cool as you
know we really love to look at the ins
and outs of anime production on this
channel but did you know you can
actually pick up authentic artwork used
in the making of some of your favorite
shows thanks to zen market you have
access to japan exclusive sites like
yahoo auction that feature a wealth of
production materials such as character
model sheets keyframes and the actual
animation cells photographed for the
shows zen market will purchase the items
for you and ship them directly to your
door and unlike other proxy services
they have a flat rate handling fee of
only three dollars this means no
surprise charges with your only
additional costs being shipping what's
great is that they'll let you gather up
items in their warehouse and ship them
all at once so you only have to pay for
postage once even across multiple stores
and if you're not interested in
production material there's also a
wealth of exclusive figures that are
often significantly cheaper than what
you would find on western sites anything
you can think of if it's sold in japan
you buy it zen market makes all this
possible and delivers worldwide so if
you're in the market for some awesome
japanese rarities then click the link in
the description or pinned comment and
see what cool stuff you can find
tale of judiah the gallant as the title
of this ark might give away this is
indeed the tale of jiraiya the gallant
you don't say as such despite there
being some developments for the likes of
sasuke and naruto respectively while i
will mention those characters briefly i
do want to focus my attention on this
incredible story surrounding jiraiya's
attempt to gain intel on the akatsuki
and the nature of an individual called
pain
following some light interrogation we
catch up with the likes of jiraya as he
arrives on the shores of this rain
village we learned some backstory
concerning pain he is apparently the
reason why the rain village is so
successfully closed off from everywhere
payne defeated hanzo the man who named
jiraya as well as tunari and orochimaru
the three great shinobi of kanoa he
coined that term and in addition to
killing him payne also killed his family
and everyone who knew him and all of
this is coming from the mouths of the
people and to be honest he sounds like
more of a legend than an actual person a
god a force of nature and more on that
in just a sec
[Music]
the fight that ensues in this arc is
different and i mean that in a good way
while there is action of a unique
variety particularly with regards to
jiraiya and what he brings to the table
there's something more grand and
prophetic about this occasion it's less
about the action and more about the
mystery as well as the internal story of
jiraiya as he fights against
increasingly insurmountable odds with
perhaps the first clue concerning his
thoughts on the future on the island
coming by way of this gesture lending
the key that unlocks naruto's full
nine-tailed fox spirit to a messenger to
deliver to naruto
himself nagato kona and yahiko were all
children jiraiya knew that were orphaned
by the war of the time but uraya decided
to mentor them however now that they
seem to be associates of pain and what
is a rather on the nose metaphor the
three of them have effectively embraced
and focused on their pain rather than
the good that they can do for the world
and want to instead enact their revenge
to make the world feel the same pain
that they were forced to feel and pain
is a word that is thrown around a ton in
this arc and it's quite obvious that
it's trying to draw a connection between
the pain character and the very concept
of pain with what it represents to these
children nagato wants to give every
nation the power to destroy each other
so that they can all know pain but what
i love about this is what jariah offers
as advice and mentorship to these young
talented and brave children instead of
focusing on how the pain is manifesting
he points out to them that those that
have gone through pain can understand it
better than anyone but they have the
capacity to feel compassion on a greater
level than anyone without that
perspective or experience and i just
thought that that was such a wonderful
way of thinking about this particular
scenario the battle with nagato or who
jiraya perceives as nagato seems
interesting but more so we see nagato
split up into three individuals that
represent pain the fight is interesting
told from jiraiya's point of view which
aids in the climax and interspliced in
this fight are a series of flashbacks
and one such flashback is called back to
once the three are taken down and a
surprise fourth person shows up only two
what was once three has now turned into
six opponents one being the pain
character himself that i recognized
apparently ahiko was said to have died
but i guess that's a metaphorical death
considering he's here to question mark
and upon closer inspection nagato
doesn't look to be among them after all
though his eyes seem to be done by
everyone what is happening here
back with the likes of sas gameco once
they arrive at the location to meet
hitachi kisame is waiting for them
apparently only sasuke is allowed to
pass and speak to his brother but not
much else happens here for me to give my
full opinion on just yet considering
this arc is primarily centering around
uriah and his current struggle he
discovers that the folks he's fighting
are all faces from his past perhaps
signifying his failures standing right
before him and now with it being six on
one
jiraya's reflection at the end of this
section is perhaps the most poetic and
beautiful section of this sprawling
sprawling story he spoke earlier in this
tale with tsunade and i knew given the
nature of his musings it would bear some
relevance to this instance in that
section he says rejection makes me
stronger the pursuit of happiness isn't
for us in that scene he speaks with a
very tongue-in-cheek flare however it
really speaks to the tragedy he sees as
his life story ashinobi's life is not
measured by how they lived but by what
they managed to accomplish before their
death and in reflecting on that very
principle he clearly holds dearly during
this short flashback jiraiya is haunted
by the failings that he thinks defined
his life until minato cuts him off and
instead praises his self-insert
character's work it's a book that he's
reading sort of like an autobiography of
his life with a renamed character it
makes one wonder more about his decision
not to accept the position of akage
since he truly feels so ashamed of what
he's done throughout his life he
probably thought he would fail in that
effort too in becoming hokage but the
message manato takes from this isn't
that of his failings but his tenacity so
much so it's inspired him to name his
son after the lead character of this
book of his
[Music]
this single turn of the page revealing
the origin of naruto's namesake had me
fighting back tears and for me this has
been the most powerful and emotional
moment so far it's not even close
executed to near perfection discovering
in his final moments that his real
selection all this time was whether or
not he would choose to fight one last
time
to select naruto to carry on long after
he's gone jiraiya was once told as a
child by the great elder that he would
have a disciple that would change the
world potentially for good and
potentially for bad it depends on a
choice and in this instance jiraiya once
again rallies himself after falling in
order to try once again and in doing so
imparts a crucial message for naruto as
to the identity of who payne really is
and as if like poetry as naruto falls to
the ground in battle and jedi fades into
the ocean declaring that his next story
should be called uzumaki naruto naruto
rises from the surface below ready to
carry on his master's will this story
was stunningly depicted
the faded battle between brothers the
vast majority of the section or arc of
the story centers around the brewing or
should i say impending conflict between
sasuke and the brother he's wished was
dead since that fateful day in many ways
this arc acts as a culmination of
sasuke's journey or at the very least a
pivotal or immeasurably important
turning point in the young character's
life i found it interesting how the
fight between hitachi and sasuke begins
with close quarters combat using a
variety of weapons and blades with all
the sign weaving in the fights leading
up to now it not only gives it a sense
of identity but also a much more
grounded honest and personal quality
blending all the more weight and frankly
to my surprise when
yeah it's uh it's not him
just like all those times in the past
hitachi seems to be one step ahead of
sasuke and anyone else really this close
quarters intimate and earnest affair
seems to be nothing more than an
illusion of an honest contest for it
okay you gotta stop doing that alright i
love this small exchange as it works
wonderfully from an audience's
perspective we begin this chapter
expecting to deal with the contest
between these two but instead it acts as
the stage for a series of illusions both
of which managed to work effectively on
me the conversation that takes place
past this point felt at least for me a
little more for exposition than it did
for character growth or revelation
necessarily having come all this way
after seeing so many spectacular battles
it doesn't seem like the fight is in any
rush to meet its resolution and i like
that it's interesting for sure getting
to see sasuke finally confront his older
brother but in retrospect the entire
affair felt very detached from reality
both literally and figuratively some
information was divulged concerning the
character of uchiem madara who too
possesses the mangekyo and in fact was
the first one to achieve such but i
think the most interesting part of this
conversation and indeed conflict comes
by way of a certain revelation the
mangakyo is a formidable weapon of
ocular ability that affords the wielder
a number of strengths otherwise not
afforded to a standard sharingan user
however when madara first possessed it
he noticed that there was a major
drawback to it that the more he used it
the more he lost his ability to see
which would be for a ninja less than
optimal in despair madara learned
something vital it was that if he took
his brother's eyes not only would he see
the light returned to his vision but he
would retain manga kyo for forever more
this for me at the time explained the
sudden shift in how hitachi treated him
growing up why he felt like a good
brother from time to time he was simply
working in his own self-interest he
wanted sasuke to stay alive as a host
for his future eyes and honestly this is
an interesting angle to take this plot
line down it clears up a ton with
regards to the mystery concerning itachi
and while it takes away a lot of his
mystique it replaces it with a whole
other brand of murderous power-driven
insanity which as sasuke finds out is
terrifying on a whole other level but
this time it seems sasuke is
significantly more skilled with the
sharingan than hitachi is with the
mangekyo eyes and so i guess it's round
two the fight itself turned out to be a
lot more competitive than i was
anticipating now naturally i wasn't
aware of the direction this fight would
take and where things would go from here
but once itachi revealed his hand i
figured some sort of resolution would be
met at this point and the visuals are
stunning in the manga i particularly
like the amaterasu technique or i guess
the black flames that engulf sasuke as
he overpowers hitachi's fire efforts
forcing itachi to dodge as the fireblast
surges into the sky above and once again
like most of the fights in this series
there's always an underlying strategy at
play and with the vision of hitachi
waning and the chakra of sasuke at its
limit something comes to the attention
of itachi it turns out all of the fire
sasuke sent flying into the air wasn't
for nothing but in fact carefully
calculated creating for him an
electrical cloud producing more energy
than anything he could conjure up on his
own and what a strike this one takes
traveling at 1 1000 of a second with
enough punch to shake a continent and
it's at this point i think back to the
kid i first met towards the beginning of
the story and how far this festering
hatred and desire for revenge has
brought him gifting him control over the
very heavens themselves it's a stunning
display of power greater than anything
i've seen once again however
that's not how this fight ends
[Music]
revealing to all of us that he has had
this trump card still up his sleeve
cornered and feeling like he's out of
options sasuke is confronted by the very
same sentence that this arc and videos
started with uttered by orochimaru so
long as you have mercy you can't best
attach it it can be seen throughout
sasuke's action in the material covered
since those words were uttered that he
has indeed shown mercy in almost every
confrontation along the path to his
brother even to those trying to kill him
and stunningly even attachy to some
extent and in being faced with these
worsening circumstances itachi unleashes
some monstrous attack sasuke's chakra
fades weaker and weaker until orochimaru
erupts forth from the depths of his
person forced to relinquish the very
humanity that made him who he was
despite him not necessarily being in
control of this move he did make the
choice to imbue himself with
orochimaru's spirit in the first place
all with hatred driving him as a
motivator i don't think it's a
coincidence that sandwich between this
pursuit of hitachi and this fated battle
between brothers is a tale effectively
describing the life and virtue of a
mentor that consistently tried to do the
right thing in the face of constant
failure who found solace and
significance not in the goals he
achieved but the desire he consistently
and earnestly expressed in doing his
best who told children who had endured
so much pain in their lives to use it
not as a vehicle for more suffering but
to use it as a motivator to emphasize
and to prevent that suffering for others
throughout these acts sasuke having
known what it's like to lose those
important to him has carried with him a
dedication to not take a life if he can
help it because he more than perhaps
anyone else he knows understands what
sort of impact and sense of sorrow that
can bring into their family and he
didn't want that for others however now
in this fight with hitachi he's willing
to throw all of that out the window he's
willing to let go of that sight of
himself if it means he gets what he
wants in other words he too was
embracing pain and when itachi takes out
orochimaru with relative ease he starts
to show very visible signs of serious
injury and fatigue coughing up blood
crying blood the battle rages on until
both are barely standing sasuke throwing
everything he has at him until he too
has nothing left and staggering towards
him in a bloody stupor is hitachi
extending his trembling hand to take
what he considers his own
sasuke's eyes
later on in this arc we get formally
introduced to a character called uchiha
madara he takes sasuke under his wing
and in doing so fills him in on some key
details concerning his now deceased
brother when itachi was very young
through his exposure to pain and
suffering and war learned to be a gentle
and peace-loving person which again
speaks to the jiraiya teachings
concerning pain and empathy for that
pain once experienced and in this
description hitachi is kind of the
opposite of madura in this situation
where madhura killed his brother for the
benefit of his own clan itachi
sacrificed his own clan for the
betterment of the wider community with
it being the case in the end he cared
more for his brother than the broader
community of people even in his dying
moments itachi wasn't trying to get his
eyes he was trying to give him his
ocular powers
to protect him and shortly following
this revelation for sasuke naruto starts
to show up in the story once again
having come to learn that his fraternal
brother sasuke had in fact achieved what
he set out to do in his last interaction
with hitachi before he teleported to
sasuke's battle hitachi presents naruto
a dilemma to contend with knowing what
we do about itachi's backstory we can
appreciate the clear connection being
drawn between what choices he was left
with and ultimately made when he was
young however naruto effectively
responds by saying that when faced with
a tough decision rife with compromise
he'd make both outcomes positive he
wouldn't kill sasuke to save his village
or vice versa he'd save his village and
he'd save sasuke there is no compromise
with naruto for him a life where he has
to compromise isn't a life he thinks is
worth living so he'd rather die trying
to get that perfect outcome rather than
live with a compromise hanging over him
for the rest of his life and i think in
a sort of childish idealistic sort of
way there's a purity and sweetness to
that sentiment that's just quite
refreshing and i think hitachi thought
so too i think this is a really
important quote towards the end of the
story and someday when you have the same
eyes as i you will find me again i think
this line is my favorite from all of the
reflection panels we receive from sasuke
because to be honest in the moment i
never took notice of that phrasing of
the sentence but knowing what i know now
it's clear to me that he meant if sasuke
can learn to understand his decisions
and empathize to see the world as he saw
it that he will be able to see him as
his brother smore a lesson that while
incredibly simple offers sasuke the
means with which to look at the world
the very same way the fight itself was
amazing the story surrounding it was
incredible and i really enjoyed reading
it and there's some stuff regarding
naruto's training and cipher sent by
giraria that i just didn't have the time
to get into this week but i will
definitely touch on it in the beginning
of the next part with that said i really
do hope that you enjoyed this video it
was really difficult to make as i had to
make a separate second video this week
addressing the whole toy situation but
i'm still really happy to be getting
back to naruto and i honestly can't wait
to see where the story takes us next if
you enjoy videos like these naruto
videos or maybe you want to see my
suffering or joy as i review all of the
batman movies from the last 60 years be
sure to subscribe it costs nothing means
the world to me and my team and you can
always unsubscribe later if you want but
that'll do for this week i've been
totally not mark and thank you all so
much for watching
[Music]
you